[Music]
we're on about total mile about 515.
when we caught up with tunnel to towers
founder frank ziller his walk from the
pentagon to the 911 memorial was nearly
over
what stood out to you the amount of kids
that are out with their parents which is
exactly one of the reasons why i wanted
to do this the younger generation kids
that weren't even born yet you know the
story is not told all the time we want
to make sure that it's always told what
happened that day
september 11 2001. frank's youngest
brother stephen was among those killed
in the terrorist attacks on the world
trade center that day his memory the
impetus for the tunnel to towers
foundation a new york city firefighter
that strapped 60 pounds on his gear and
ran through the brooklyn battery tunnel
because it was closed and he ran through
that zone came out the other side and
saw a horrific scene but there are 343
stories
of firefighters that did similar things
like stephen did there are so many
stories the foundation's mission to
honor their sacrifice like with this
year's walk from the pentagon to
shanksville to the battery tunnel trip
steven ziller took to ground zero it's
going to be very difficult of course
i'll be thinking of stephen and i know
the difference
i'm walking
he ran with his gear on i'm going to see
the freedom tower and look at what he
saw the twin towers on fire but
nonetheless i'm trying to do something
to honor my brother and this is what i
thought i could do and i'm glad i did it
and they truly honor so many more than
just those who gave their lives on 911
they've expanded to police and
firefighters that lose their lives now
taking care of their families military
members so much good work that they are
doing yeah steven's story was one of the
first i heard and if you've ever been in
one of those tunnels underneath the
rivers
i can't imagine with full gear on
running through what a courageous
courageous moment if you want to hear
more of the interview we have the full
interview with frank siller on our cbs
morning's podcast